hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
so I've got a lot of videos brewing in
the pipeline but I thought I'll just put
out a quick video on my thoughts on
Apple's recent developer conference the
iPad announcements in particular caught
my attention so back in 2010 when the
iPad was first introduced I gave the
feel of what people were thinking when I
asked the people that I knew what they
thought of the new category from Apple
it seemed that they were all laughing
about the idea the main reason being the
iPad was essentially a big iPhone in the
end Apple was ultimately successful and
did change the landscape of tablet
computing which was atrocious at the
time it's an ultra mobile tablet it's
all that you need for a primary
computing device in a fairly small
2-pound of 1 kilo package but the
limited software capabilities still hung
over the iPad product although the user
experience was leaps and bounds above
the competition the capabilities lagged
behind
as time passed this functionality gap
became glaringly obvious to everyone for
me personally I've been interested in
mobile technology blending into PCs
since my first Android phone and made a
very public attempt to make this happen
in 2012 when I tried to make my Samsung
Galaxy Note 2 function as a PC even then
it was clear how much extra utility USB
an external file storage gave a device
for the iPad especially over the last
two years it's definitely outgrown its
software technically it's a marvel a
slim and light device as powerful as a
core i7
20:18 macbook pro it's a true computer
crippled by limited iphone software in
my last Apple video I called it a huge
missed opportunity no mouse support no
extra storage support and the file
management system was a not so funny
joke this has all changed in its latest
developer conference in early June Apple
finally addressed a lot of these issues
by giving the iPad its own OS called
iPad OS I've heard OS means that for the
first time the device finally has the
freedom to do more it's now an
in-between category between the Mac and
the iPhone which is what the iPad should
have been to begin with I'd imagine that
Apple likes to keep his category simple
and would want to prevent the iPad
eating into macbook sales
probably two main factors which
prevented this from happening
but for Apple this move was a no-brainer
three of the biggest changes are a file
manager overhaul USB support and mouse
support the mouse support was discovered
by a dev playing around with the new
iPad OS it's hard for me to believe that
the last two took so long but it's
definitely a step in the right direction
for Apple as the iPad clearly deserved
more seeing as once again the device was
as powerful as a 20-18 macbook pro for
the file manager there's now a column
view for going into folder hierarchies
and quick action and metadata details
USB support is as it sounds
USB drives hard drives and SD cards will
now be supported importing directly from
digital cameras works now to other
changes include more icons in the home
grid and widgets as well
improved multitasking tweaks also made
an appearance
this increases the ease of productivity
on the go and also now supports multiple
instances of the same app desktop class
browsing now prevents baby mobile web
pages from being displayed in addition a
download manager is now supported I find
that one simply hard to believe in 2019
a whole bunch of keyboard shortcuts are
also coming to the iPad so overall I
think this is great I think Apple had a
great product in the iPad and now
they're making the most of it but I
think this is all just more than the
iPad as I stated in my previous Apple
video the iPad pro is ARM architecture
in the form of an in-house built chip
may make it a platform for the future of
Apple's computing this is due to the arm
architectures less bloated instruction
set in that video I also predicted that
the iPad was a new glimpse into the
future direction of Apple hardware so it
makes sense to me that Apple is starting
to take the iPad products a little more
seriously now so I think it's all very
interesting but what do you guys think
I'm interested to know your thoughts on
the new operating system for iPads but
in saying that for Apple things aren't
going to be smooth sailing going forward
in an art coming video you'll see that
Apple may be getting sued by the Supreme
Court for breaking antitrust laws
resulting in losses potentially in the
billions but that's for another day so
thanks for watching this has been to
gogo and you've been watching ColdFusion
if he did like this video and want to
see more on Science and Technology
definitely consider subscribing and I'll
see you again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
you